[Music]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream it is live stream
number 92 with me dr brett weinstein
this is dr heather heing sitting to my
right which
i don't know enough about video to know
whether she's on your right but in any
case she is here
i am here we are here in bark we have
some announcements we have announcements
we have three ads today which we do at
the top of the hour and then we will
jump right in
uh so we're going to be talking a little
bit uh about uh the current cultural
moment just briefly at the top of the
hour and then we're going to spend most
the most the time today talking about
childhood
following from uh chapter 8 chapter 9 of
our forthcoming book a hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century which is all
about childhood so we're going to be
talking about childhood and us and
others the value of play unstructured
and otherwise the value of risk all of
these things
but first if you're watching this on
youtube consider trying it on odyssey we
know that there are buffering problems
they're working on it the chat is live
on odyssey but uh not on youtube the
moderators were having too difficult a
time moderating two different chats at
once so if you're here live right now
can go to odyssey for the chat
you can ask questions at
darkhorsesubmissions
consider joining our patreons
uh we will say a little bit more about
that at the end of the hour you can go
to dark horse podcast no you can go to
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
to buy dark horse shirts and goliath
shirts and such
consider joining me at my new endeavor
on substance
naturalselections.substance.com this
week's
read was on polyandry
and um as i said we're going to do three
ads today drink walk lounge
rinse repeat we've got three and we
really you know we don't we don't accept
sponsors that have products that we
don't actually stand by we we reject
more than we accept from the amazing guy
who brings us these opportunities and
these
three today two of which are new to us
uh we really stand behind so without
further ado let's embark on the ads
[Music]
all right first one is for four sigmatic
a wellness company known for its
delicious mushroom coffee mushroom
coffee you say well that sounds odd
maybe not what you want i was skeptical
but i've been drinking it lately when i
want coffee with something extra and
it's very very good
four sigmatics mushroom coffee contains
yes coffee organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee but it also has
lion's mane mushroom for productivity
and i mentioned lion's mane mushroom
last week
as something that is gaining uh
gaining followers in the west having
long been
something that is used as part of a
health and wellness routine in many
parts of the east and also chaga
mushroom
for immune support
so i've begun uh to drink four sigmatic
ground mushroom coffee with lion's mane
instead of regular coffee sometimes and
it does seem to add a little something
little extra crispness and focus the
world seems just a little more clear
after i drink it it's delicious just
like regular coffee you can't taste the
mushrooms if that's what you're worried
about as i was
but no this tastes just like your
favorite coffee dark and nutty and
and
delicious
um so all four sigmatic products are
organic vegan and gluten-free every
single batch is third-party lab tested
to ensure its purity and safety so you
know you're getting the highest quality
coffee and mushrooms possible it's got
over 20 000 star reviews baxter products
with a hundred percent money back
guarantee so you love it or you get your
money back
so we have worked out an exclusive offer
with four sigmatic on their best-selling
mushroom coffee this is just for dark
horse listeners get up to forty percent
off and free shipping on mushroom coffee
bundles to claim this deal you must go
to 4sigmatic.com darkhorse
this offers only for darkhorse listeners
not available on their regular website
you'll save up to 40 get free shipping
so go right now to f o u r
s i g m a t i c
dot com slash dark horse and fuel your
productivity and creativity with some
delicious mushroom coffee
that's our first sponsor for today our
second is vivo barefoot
view barefoot is on a mission to create
regenerative footwear and experiences
that bring you closer to nature and your
natural potential
the evil barefoot makes shoes for feet
and we have a script here but um let's
just go off script here for a little bit
um these shoes are fabulous they look
they are they have you noticed that they
look a little weird um but we they they
were interested in uh being a sponsor of
dark horse they are they are fans and we
are now extraordinary fans of them we've
been wearing their shoes almost
exclusively you know we have we have
dedicated bike shoes with cleats in them
and such um for you know for other
moments but
i can go forever in these shoes yeah
it's amazing how much the other shoes
that we have from before we had these
shoes are just kind of sitting around
they're lonely they are a little lonely
yeah so the thing is they do look a
little weird the first time you see them
take them out of the box and they don't
they look foot shaped they look foot
shaped that's the thing is what you
realize when you put these shoes on and
then you walk around is that actually
regular shoes look weird and these look
the way shoes should work because the
theory here is that shoes can strain
your foot in a way that's bad and what
hypothesis yeah well hypothesis but i
think it's actually uh fairly well
established at this point
shoes constrain the foot and so the
ideal thing you can't walk around
barefoot in most urban environments you
wouldn't want to for lots of reasons so
a shoe that allows you to be barefoot
inside the shoe doesn't compress your
foot will look different than a regular
shoe but in order not to be sloppy like
a slipper it has to hold you firmly so
it holds you firmly right near the ankle
and it actually has a thin sole you can
feel the ground underneath you it's
quite a different experience and i
really really like it yeah it can it
constrains your ankle so that you're not
having to use your toes in an unnatural
way to keep your feet onto your shoe the
way flip-flops do
which many podiatrists good podiatrists
will tell you are not particularly good
for foot health and
it may surprise some long time viewers
who are familiar with some of the trials
and tribulations that i have experienced
physically that i also was born with
genetically very weird feet and had
massive reconstructive surgery at 13
which allowed me to become the athlete
i'd always wanted to be
um and you know really walk um you know
walk and run and play and all of this um
but it does mean that i've got touchy
feet and i'll you know basically always
have and not in these shoes like really
not in these shoes they're really really
quite extraordinary so uh we'll be
coming back to you again and again with
um with
advocation that's not a word advocacy
advocacy for vevo barefoot but let me
say now
that uh you can uh go to
vivobarefoot.com
darkhorse to get an exclusive offer of
20 off
additionally all new customers get a 100
day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do seriously try
them that's vivo barefoot v i v o
b a r e
o
dot com slash darkhorse
go try them out uh we really think
you'll like them
yup i'm very interested to see if uh
they spread as a phenomenon as people
try them on and discover what they've
been missing indeed all right uh our
last sponsor
for this week is alform sofas
so
what makes an alform sofa terrific an
alform sofa is a sofa that you can
customize you can customize the material
that you're going to use you can
customize the layout in your living room
and then they ship it to you and you
assemble it we got one of these and toby
and i put it together in a couple of
hours
i must say i have done some furniture
building in my day some design and some
building and i always whenever we go for
furniture to buy something i always look
at the construction because it matters
in the end more than almost anything
else and i was i was dubious about this
because a modular sofa has many more
places that something can go wrong that
it can creak or fall apart or something
like that
but they've developed an amazing system
for bolting these things together so you
really do get a fully rigid very
beautiful sofa but it has the advantage
that if you were to for example get a
layout and then want to reverse it for a
different room or reverse it because
you've rearranged the way things are in
your room you can do that you can unbolt
it and put it together in a different
way
the construction is excellent the
comfort is fantastic and in our case we
got a sofa that we think is absolutely
beautiful so
highly recommended uh you should go to
let's see alform
dot com a-l-l-f-o-r-m.com
dark horse
and they have arranged a 20
off all offer all orders from our
listeners at again a-l-l-f-o-r-m-com
dark horse so check it out
okay we're done with the answer thank
you
um and an homage to sesame street
uh today's episode is also brought to
you by the number 92 and the letter t
that's t
so the hunter gatherer's guide to the
21st century has as its index entries
for the letter t
as follows
taboos taino tajik children tarahumara
technological frontiers teeth temporal
rites of passage tetrapods thc theory of
mind throughput society the rise of
tinkering titanic td monkeys tolstoy leo
um toluene can never pronounce that
toluene
tools tortoises trade-off relationships
allocation trade-offs design constraint
trade-offs diversity fueled by freedom
justice tradeoff generalist versus
specialist traditions transfer of
resource frontiers tree frogs trivers
bob turtles and of course
tyranny
awesome turtles and tyranny turtles
trade-offs in tyranny in the same
section of the index turtles trivers
trade-offs and tyranny wow yeah
i mean if you needed to bring four
things with you to a picnic that
wouldn't be a bad set i think it would
be oh
yeah can we at least drop the tyranny
please right but
bring bob to the picnic oh absolutely
we've had bob i don't know if i don't
want a picnic but we had him at our
wedding yes yeah he was the official he
was the efficient at our wedding bob if
you're out there
okay so um you wanted to start and then
uh and then we'll
then we'll continue yes well we'll start
we'll start at the beginning and then
we'll continue yes i have a thoroughly
uncomfortable story which under ordinary
circumstances i would not tell here for
all sorts of reasons i have of course
cleared it with you heather um but yet i
don't and yet i don't remember
a lot of things you remember okay you'll
know right away okay um and they will be
able to read it in the horror on your
face um so
heather and i had an argument this week
yes right now i must say i don't feel
terrible about this because all couples
have arguments and i think it takes time
to learn how to have a proper argument
how to be humane to each other but we
have done very well in this regard we
don't have many arguments and when we do
have arguments they tend to be over
things that matter and we are humane to
each other in these arguments
nonetheless we had an argument this week
and
uh i must say just an aside
in the middle of this argument speaking
to your humanity um
you delivered i don't know if you know
this part but you delivered one of the
most amazing compliments in my entire
life wow right so there was a section of
the argument in which you
gave a list of uh
really extraordinary um qualities of
mine that you uh you find uh i don't
know worthy of a steam or something like
that and then there was a kind of a
however sure right and then i don't
remember what came after that but there
was a very there was a long list of
compliments and they were really high
quality ones and so anyway that meant a
lot to me thank you
actually i do remember what came after
however but i know you do so you're not
there wasn't a particular thing in that
list or it was just the fact of the life
it was to have somebody that you love
and admire deliver like a distilled list
of your best characteristics and maybe
even described in overly generous terms
it was
it was key i'll remember it no i mean i
think part of
part of presumably why it landed as well
as it did i
i didn't know this but um is that you
know in the middle of an argument it's
hard to imagine that the person that
you're arguing with is at their most
generous and so right you know i was i
was being honest i was trying to be
honest so you know i don't i don't think
the list of
extraordinary features that you have and
skills that you have and traits that you
bring was in any way an exaggeration
well
in any case whatever that list was uh i
i enjoyed it and i also did get the
point and and that really is you know
when one argues you tend to not be in
your best frame of mind and be defensive
and to have somebody deliver the good
and the bad together is is uh
is is a very good thing but anyway the
point of this story is the following
thing
the next day i was looking at reddit and
i got an ad
for divorce attorneys
yeah
and i'm the reason i'm telling this
story is to cover your ass i know well
here's the thing i am certain divorce
was never mentioned in our argument no
so
what the hell were they listening to
what did they was it raised voices was
it was somebody listening to content
what exactly triggered i mean obviously
there's a remote chance it was a
coincidence but i have never seen an ad
for a divorce attorney
in any scrolling i've done anywhere as
far as i can recall yeah so it's a
pretty unusual thing to show up i've
definitely had one i didn't get those
ads
weird all right i wasn't on reddit
that's true we didn't run the control
yeah um but but anyway there's something
very odd about this i've had lots of
coincidences i've seen people attempt to
test whether or not these coincidences
are purely coincidental or whether or
not they um represent something
listening you know you're you're looking
for an object you discuss an object that
you might want to buy with your partner
and then suddenly you start getting ads
for it even though neither of you has
typed it into anything and then amazon
can deliver it to you miraculously the
same day the same day as a matter of
fact it's outside your door just click
this button but anyway the point is
we are
definitely in a brave new world and you
know we can hope that that was some
automatic algorithm that nobody is
paying attention in detail to when we
fight or whatever else we might be doing
but
i think the chances if this was just
simply some low-level algorithmic thing
the chances that that lasts and that
somebody doesn't start collecting such
information and utilizing it in order to
gain power and disempower those that
challenge them is zero and my bet and i
must say i've been saying this for 20
years
at some point
the thing that collects all this data
right just sort of
as a matter of course rather than
because you've been targeted it just
hoovers it up it sticks it somewhere it
can do something that i would call
retroactive surveillance right it can go
back through your history and it can
figure out what it didn't care about at
the time but is now useful to it right
retroactive surveillance have you become
a person of interest
you have become a person of interest and
therefore your past is now relevant and
we own it right that's a very
frightening that's much worse than
somebody having to notice you and then
start spying on you which is bad enough
yeah and and the distinction
philosophically and analytically between
like post-addiction and prediction is
huge this is and this is the latter this
is mining
as opposed to uh hypothesis generation
and prediction right and um it results
in the possibility of what i've tried to
describe as some kind of light-handed
surgical tyranny right where if you can
if you've got everybody's data and you
just leave everyone alone until somebody
causes you trouble and then you go after
them in a concentrated way the point is
you don't have to harass most people all
you have to do is disrupt the lives of
those who would make change and nothing
changes so if your point is let's keep
the status quo because we are doing well
in it and this is a perfect weapon for
that sort of thing so
anyway i don't know what we are to do
about this friends i really don't but i
do think
um
the problem is that the people in your
life who sound like they may be overly
concerned about the devices we carry in
our pockets for example probably none of
us are concerned enough i noticed that
ed snowden
had a thing i can't remember what the
main topic of the article was but it
started out by saying when he gets a new
phone the first thing he does is remove
the hidden microphones in it right
there are things in there that can be
used to transduce sound and he actually
physically removes them because what
else could you do right
so anyway let this be a warning to us
all
they are monitoring things apparently
that we don't think they're monitoring
and you know
barring a very weird coincidence that is
a pretty strong indicator in my opinion
because you know random divorce attorney
ads probably aren't um
all that profitable profitable so yeah
anyway end of story but i do think
there's something to be concerned about
yeah indeed so that's that's where you
were going to go yep that's it all right
um i will also say for those who are in
the pacific northwest you will know this
we've had um i don't know is it our
third maybe you know
incredible heat wave this week and it's
a little bit cooler today but
uh it it combined with a change in air
patterns such that the smoke from the
fires is finally coming down a little
bit so you know not only is our ac on
which is drying things out but the air
quality is terrible and so you know
point of order apologies for the the
cough
we are having our third heat wave this
summer this week
yeah what did i say uh it implied it but
you said we're having our third heat
wave this week and i just sort of think
about this one heat wave yeah yeah i
know this uh yeah yeah you're right
you're right and it didn't it didn't get
to 116 like it did the first time in the
end of june which was insane um and you
know
breaking records by um by several digits
but um by several rather by several um
integers uh but it did hit triple digits
and it's it's been it's you know it's
had the air has had that yellow it
hasn't it hasn't gone into orange or red
tinge like it did during the fires last
september but it's had that sort of
pre-apocalyptic feeling to it which you
know was sort of a decent match for a
lot of things um but we are not going to
spend time on the apocalypse today no no
we're going to spend time on childhood
which is like it's the opposite of the
apocalypse it's actually a hedge against
apocalypse that's what childhood is in
some ways
um and we're going to start so this is
um
as as regular listeners will know we are
going chapter by chapter through our our
book a hunter-gatherer's guide to the
21st century which is coming out
september 14th 2021
and uh doing an excerpt or two from each
of the successive chapters and then
talking about it and so i actually have
a couple of excerpts for this week um
that i'm going to read we're going to
talk about and then i have some other
some other supporting
information to uh to share so without
further ado we're going to start with
just the first three pages of the
childhood chapter so it's a
all of these chapters really um go so
many places and so even if you feel like
oh you're reading excerpts i pretty much
know what's in the book no every single
chapter has a ton more than anything
we're talking about
so chapter nine
childhood
childhood is a time of exploration
it is a time to learn rules to break
rules and to make new rules
when our older son zach was five years
old he innovated a new mode of
locomotion downstairs which involved a
large rubber ball and a mattress
it worked well until it didn't
his arm break required the surgical
insertion of metal pins to stabilize the
growth plate of his hume
humerus and another surgery six weeks
later to remove them but he healed
beautifully and innovated with more
wisdom going forward
a young orangutan following his mother
through the trees may whimper and call
for her upon reaching a gap that is too
large for him to cross
she will return and bridge the gap
allowing him both to cross and to see
how it is done
young ravens spend years in large social
groups after they become independent
from their parents and before they form
pair bonds with long-term partners
alliances formed during this time but
conflicts also arise and those ravens
that figure out how to reconcile with
one another experience less aggression
going forward
when a young snow monkey named imo
innovated cleaning her sweet potatoes by
dipping them into the sea the adults in
her troop were slow to take notice they
lived together on a tiny island in japan
but only two adults in the troop copied
her behavior over the next five years
the young monkeys though the other
children and sub-adults watched and
learned
five years on nearly 80 percent of the
juvenile monkeys were cleaning their
sweet potatoes in the style of emo
during childhood we learn how to be
we also learn who we are and we dream
about who we might become
humans are not blank slates but of all
organisms on earth we are the blankest
we have the longest childhoods on earth
and we arrive in the world with more
plasticity than any other species
meaning that we are the least set in
stone
software which is the interplay of
experience and knowledge with capacity
is more important than humans than any
other species
a profound demonstration of this can be
seen in the peopling of the americas
a handful of ancestors came into the new
world with stone age technology and
diversified into hundreds of cultures
across two continents inventing writing
astronomy architecture and city-states
along the way the piece the pace of
change being far too rapid to be
attributable to genes it all took place
on the software side
our ability to learn language is part of
our hardware nearly all human babies
have this competence latent in them
which language a baby will speak however
is entirely context dependent that's
software
furthermore we quickly lose some of our
ability to hear and construct the
phonemes and tones of languages that are
not in our environment regardless of our
particular ethnicity or lineage
just as we are born with more neuronal
potential than we use most of our
neurons die off before we become adults
we are also born with linguistic
potential than we use and some of it is
lost during childhood we are born with
broad potential and that potential
narrows over time
on its surface the paring down of
initial capacity may seem like a
tremendous waste so why do we do it
the answer is that when we are born we
are in a mode of exploration we cannot
predict ahead of time precisely what
neurons we will need what language we
will speak so we are born with a surplus
of capacity
this permits us to optimize our minds to
whatever world we find ourselves born
into without the need for prior
knowledge we are born to explore the
world around us discover its secrets and
structure our minds accordingly once
this job is done we shed our surplus
capacity unless to become a metabolic
liability all cost and no reward
humans are social with long life spans
and have overlap between generations
grandparents parents and children may
all live in the same place at the same
time
these characteristics also apply to the
other apes to the toothed whales
dolphins and orcas and elephants to
parrots and corvids crows and jays
wolves and lions and more
all species that are social are
long-lived and have generational overlap
also tend to have long childhoods
these other species childhoods come with
tantrums and play emotional depth and
cognitive capacity just like ours
the adults that develop from those
children of other species of social
complexity is recognizable to us humans
as well
spinner dolphins choreograph elaborate
group hunts new caledonian crows share
information among their friends
elephants grieve
spending time as children allows animals
to learn about their environment
therefore stealing childhood from the
young by organizing and scheduling their
play for them by keeping them from risk
and exploration by controlling and
sedating them with screens and
algorithms and legal drugs practically
guarantees that they will arrive at the
age of adulthood without being capable
of actually being adults
all of these actions almost always well
intentioned prevent the human software
from refining our crude and rudimentary
hardware
absent childhood animals must rely more
fully on hardware and therefore be less
flexible
among migratory bird species those that
are born knowing how when and where to
migrate those that are migrating
entirely with instructions they were
born with
sometimes have wildly inefficient
migration routes these birds born
knowing how to migrate don't adapt
easily
so when lakes dry up forest becomes
farmland or climate change pushes
breeding grounds farther north those
birds that are born knowing how to
migrate keep flying by the old rules and
maps
by comparison birds with the longest
childhoods and those that migrate with
their parents tend to have the most
efficient migration routes
childhood facilitates the passing out of
cultural information and culture can
evolve faster than genes
childhood gives us flexibility in a
changing world
hell yeah so much important there that
um
can give you insight into how the world
works why it looks the way it does and
how you might live better if you know
how to extrapolate from it which we do
in that chapter
um yeah it leads me to
a couple of
thoughts one i'm very interested to see
whether the world will figure out
the blankest slant slate point right
that we
so just to reiterate we aren't blankists
we are not blank slates but we are the
blankest of all life on earth right we
are born with the most capacity to
become something we are not yet and so
this puzzle there's a couple layers to
this puzzle one
people will have heard us talk many
times about the fact that sex is in fact
binary whether we like it or not right
it just simply is
um so in this case binary thinking is
actually where you want to start now
there's lots of in the case of sex
sexual cases
right and then you could say actually
the software uh which is gender is much
more variable but the sex isn't right so
there's a binary aspect there's a more
continual aspect with this heavily
bimodal but not perfectly so
or it is bimodal but it is uh if there's
at least uh
stuff from one end of the continuum to
the other that's right but anyway the
point is we tend to be
binary in our thinking reflexively and
that has not served us well with respect
to the um
the so-called nature nurture debate the
uh blank slate-ism which is preposterous
the rebellion against blank slateism
which is preposterous right both of
these things are wrong and so how do you
even formulate this and just the simple
recognition just the fact the fact that
human beings are just
the blankest slate by virtue of the fact
that the amount of our behavioral
repertoire that has been offloaded to a
flexible
uh portion of the mind that is actually
loaded in after we are born is greater
than any other creature that's an
amazing fact and understanding its
implication right and where that puts us
in this non-binary discussion
is crucial so you know i don't know
whether
uh the book will have this effect on the
discussion but understanding that you
are not being clever to say we are not
blank slates right
if you do not follow it up with
given
that is one end of a continuum and we
are closer to it than anything else then
what are we to infer right exactly and
um
it's not to suggest
that we have any less genetic input at
an absolute level than than our brethren
and than everything else on the planet
um but that we have so much more that
that contributes to us becoming what we
are that you know at the absolute level
we are you know we are genetic um in
makeup just as just as chimps are just
as chanterelle mushrooms are just as
cedars are
uh just as giraffes are uh but we have
in addition as you know
and and as with so many of these things
and we talk about this in the book a lot
we've got the sort of nested sets of
like yeah actually all mammals have a
fair bit
of of learning to do and some mammals
don't do very much but because of that
you know initial innovation of milk of
mother's milk which then allows for the
evolution of love and allows for the
transmission not just of you know
nutrients and immunological information
through the actual milk but the tactile
bonding and then the then just the
spending time together that then allows
for the further evolution of more time
that is spent in childhood all mammals
have some some kind of
juvenile phase that could be called
childhood but there are you know the
usual suspects as as i call them those
organisms that are long-lived and social
with generational overlap you know as as
we say in this excerpt i just read
almost always also tend to have long
childhoods and you know childhood being
that period between birth and um
you know it varies in over a non-human
animal space we tend to say age of first
reproduction
but of course there's a tremendous
amount of time which in humans we call
sort of puberty or adolescence um
after which you are technically capable
of reproducing but before which uh you
are can really be considered a full
adult and so all of that is what work
it's
considering in this concept of childhood
you know during which time different
cultures have different
have different timings and actually
that's the next excerpt that i'll read
maybe that's a good segue but um all
just as just as
all mammals throughout history have
provided milk to their young
all humans throughout history
have a period of time during which uh
the children are at first completely
helpless and then somewhat less helpless
and then ever more ability to ever more
able to help themselves but at the same
time
benefiting from
being in the family setting being
being able to observe what elders do
what youngers do to teach to learn to
interact to play all of these things are
part of
are not an after effect they aren't sort
of what you do and we'll get to this too
they aren't what you do to fill time
because you're stuck in childhood they
are the reason for childhood they are
the reason for childhood and and we
should say
you know it's very easy to jump too
early to a conclusion right so we have
more that is
divorced from the genes
i didn't mean that um i'm just waiting
for my phone to pick up on the word
divorced and
i see
more ads but um
no the the fact that the genes have uh
surrendered control over our behavioral
repertoire is not an indication that the
other part of us has staged a coup and
that's another
key feature of the book is that we
describe the relationship between the
software and the hardware and the point
is they actually agree on the hardware's
objectives for both better and worse
right it makes understanding what we are
much simpler but the point is the genes
have offloaded the work to the software
layer because it is done better and
faster not because they have given up
any control
or they've given up proximate control
but they haven't given up control over
ultimate objectives and that is in many
ways the greatest obstacle that we face
is that we have this sort of
default inherited purpose which is the
same as the purpose of every other
creature and therefore
not a worthy purpose for creatures like
us who
have values that are not best matched to
that uh you know most fundamental
evolutionary
objective
so anyway we have to grapple with that
and i guess the third thing which you
hinted at in passing here
is that childhood
as much as it is an amazing time is
actually an unavoidable cost
in order to get the software part loaded
well you have to have a childhood it's a
cost that you have to endure
if you think about the way selection has
to view this childhood is a big risk
right it's because childhood is long and
and dangers are
many
there's every possibility to invest in
someone and have them never reach
a reproductive capacity so it's a cost
that is born because it must be born in
order to get the benefits of it which
are this amazing flexibility right the
difference between being stuck with a
migratory route or being able to change
your migratory route to be more
efficient yeah and i i just i love that
result i remember when i first came up
across that about the migratory birds
that are born knowing where to go and
those that are learning it from their
parents on the fly quite literally um
i i used to share that um in my
vertebrate evolution programs and i when
i taught that and
you know i've seen i've seen no update
but it also you know stands it hasn't
been falsified this
this idea that even for birds traveling
long distances
um if you have someone
with whom you can do an interplay
in real time go like oh this or that
this or that as opposed to
i know what to do when i'm doing it how
how would you learn under those
conditions it's got to be a very very
drastic change for a migratory bird
who's born knowing is born with the
instructions on board for where to go
and how to get there uh to change that
up right it's it's the very clumsy
process that we describe in the bio 101
textbook rather than the upgraded
process that selection has discovered
that allows for the rapid honing in on a
new innovative way of doing something
better well and then you know
yeah don't get us started on textbooks
right like in in this is in so many
things what's in the textbook is
um
hopefully was generally thought to be
right at the point that it was written
uh it never describes the actual process
by which we arrive at what we think to
be true that is it doesn't describe the
actual scientific process it may
describe the conclusions of the
scientific process
and it doesn't it tends to
simplify to the point of caricature
which often then ends up introducing
inaccuracy
usually unintentional um but you know so
often textbook versions of things as
opposed to
deep dives and discussions about what
the implications are will lead you
astray and this is you know this is this
is why this is sort of the basis for
this
thing that people say you know a little
knowledge can be a bad thing right you
know you know a little bit and you think
you know
you know you think you know what
evolution is you think you know what
science is and then you speak with the
authority from a textbook as opposed to
the authority of having dug deep and
tried to think through
what would this mean what are the
implications if a b and c then what what
will follow and that of course is a
large part of what we're trying to do
here and
yeah evolutionary lens i mean i've i've
changed my opinion a little bit on
what's going on in the textbooks i mean
textbooks themselves are a troubling
phenomenon and let me just say school is
next week so we'll get we'll come back
here we'll get there yeah but
if you think about just the process of
science and textbooks as sort of a
an instantaneous description of the
model as it stands right they're not
perfect they're written
so as to be understood they're not
necessarily the top quality thinking
they should lean in that direction as
often as possible but if you think about
science as a process that builds models
that predict behavior of stuff
and those models as they get closer and
closer to the truth predict better and
better right the number of factors that
they exclude drops
the textbook in theory should grow
and its ability to predict what takes
place in any particular instance should
go up but at some level this is not so
different from the much more normal
process of understanding the world
around you whether it be the social
world or whether it be the sport that
you play or or whatever you know you
have some model something you you say
that isn't exactly true right and so
in the book we talk about literally
false metaphorically true things but the
degree to which that applies to every
realm
right in sport for example um the idea
that you have to follow through
right on your swing at the baseball yeah
right you're not affecting the baseball
after it has left the bat following
through is not what works it's the
planning to follow through that causes
you to hit the baseball properly and
then everything after that is just what
happens right
so does that matter no the best way to
teach somebody to hit the baseball
properly is to tell them to follow
through right
yeah i remember this um
i played more tennis than baseball as a
kid even before this foot surgery that i
had um
and i remember
in a stubborn moment which i had a few
of like what if i don't yeah what if i
don't follow through
and um
and i i could just tell i could just
tell as a kid there's no way i
understand the physics well enough i
have scientifically informed people in
my life and even though i'm a kid i know
that this can't matter
but i couldn't if i knew i wasn't
following through i could not play as
effective tennis as if i didn't think it
and part of it is that part of it is
that um you can reach that sort of flow
state more easily if you aren't trying
to stop the thing as soon as as soon as
you leave as soon as the rack the ball
leaves the racket right right that's
part of it but it's also that
there's actually in order to stop the
racket afterwards you have to invest in
the stopping of it and that gets in the
road of the thing that you're doing so
imagine that follow through actually
matters
it does matter but it doesn't matter for
the advertised reason right obviously
anybody anybody who plays one of these
things can figure that out but um but
the point is no it's still the best way
to teach it and you know how do you
figure out what's going to happen on a
billiard table right well newtonian
mechanics is wrong but it's not so wrong
that we don't still teach it because
it's still really freaking useful at
slow speeds right
um so anyway
these are models they contain a degree
so just to fill that out you're not you
don't teach einstein to people learning
pool right right
it would be that would be pointless
right it would be pointless right if
you're trying to understand what's going
to happen the the added value of doing
it uh the more rigorous way is not
matched by the added complication of it
and so you have this approximate model
that works really well and
um so that's that's good enough
um
one last thing before we move on to the
next segment yeah i mean it's really
it's quite it's about plasticity so it's
all in in this space
all right well i think i think i'm going
to put this here
because it was raised by the initial
thing that you read which talked about
languages and the loss of the ability to
use phonemes from languages that uh
don't overlap your own if if you don't
hear them uh or i think use them as
a very young person
and i'm
there's a part of me that's very wistful
about some of the things that
woke culture has
eliminated from the landscape and one of
them
is language play between different
cultures and i know we've spent lots of
time at field stations with people from
all over the world we've traveled to
many different places that there's a
certain joy
in
playing with accents
right it is especially fun to
try to let other
people be if somebody speaks spanish as
their native language and they've
learned english
trying to do a spanish accent so they
can hear what the accent sounds like
um trying to do a spanish accent in
english right
right it's it's great and you know and
you might think oh that's really
insensitive no i i love it when people
do this to us too and it you know this
is the kind of thing that people who
have played across languages everybody
loves it and anybody who can do it
really well is the life of the party
right it's you know it's an important
thing and i'm reminded of this uh
routine and it's the kind of humor in
which there is recognition it's not
denigrating it's not exclusionary it's
not tribal except in that it recognizes
that yes those of us who speak different
languages do in that one way at least
belong to different tribes but if we're
trying to reach across those tribes if
we're trying to just recognize hey we're
different and it's cool and we want to
communicate here's how you sound to me
how do i sound to you right right and
you know there are i remember jokes
about particular errors that people from
particular language groups would tend to
make in your language that basically
create inadvertent puns and things and
the points
unintentional jokes
no no the jokes are a retelling that is
based on a
predictable failure of somebody from a
language group and you know the point is
it's just too sensitive you couldn't do
such a thing now but it was never
disrespectful right we all know that we
do this in the other's language right
that's just the way it is and um and so
hearing this is just it enriches you you
you are able to put yourself in the mind
of somebody else hearing the way you
speak it probably increases the way the
acuity with which you speak in another
language yeah i know i spend a lot of
time sort of
goofing off
you know speaking english with accents
from around the world
based on what i've heard you know and i
don't i don't find anything wrong with
it i know there's no disrespect in it
but i'm reminded of
this uh
musical comedy routine this entirely
italian
comedian what was his name it's uh
andriano
celentano
and the the song
the video is very dated and as far as i
know there's not a really good version
of it the the video is actually degraded
because i think it was recorded on
videotape and there's no
master that has re-emerged but
uh but anyway are we gonna are we gonna
link to this yeah we could okay the song
is called uh
prison colin incinesouzo
right not helpful no uh here i have the
spelling there um anyway the point of
the song was it was a kind of elaborate
um
elaborate musical
song with a kind of fanciful rock star
character this uh italian comedian um
sort of a slick guy
singing what appears to be a song in
english except there are no english
words in it it's what english sounds
like to a town it's like it's full of
english phone names but it's not full of
english words right and so for italians
who don't speak english or speak it a
little bit it's what it sounds like it's
what an english pop song would sound
like right and it is very catchy right
and it appears to be full of meaning
right you know it starts out with him
lecturing to a class full of attractive
young women and he's the cool handsome
teacher or something like this and then
he breaks into a song and dance routine
and never does it right it's as one does
sure um
but anyway the point is there was
nothing disrespectful about this quite
the opposite it was italians telling
you know
english speakers who had taken over the
world of pop music what their music
sounded like to them which is what we
hear and it's not we're saying how dare
you or this is gross or we don't like
this like right that's what we hear no
it's awesome i actually it occurs to me
that
hearing you talk here
that one of the many reasons that i love
being
in places where i don't speak the
language and i always try to speak
enough to be respectful and to get along
and i you know you and i have talked
about this on air and in life for
decades now i really wish that i had
more facility with other languages but
uh my spanish is enough to get along by
with at this point my french is enough
to get and you know my malagasy not
really and you know when we've got when
we were in turkey we learned a few words
enough to be you know
informed but that was really it
so being in a place really any place
even in latin america where i do speak
enough with the language that i can i
can now recognize
the chatter around me enough at least to
know sort of what the context is
but it's it's like this intermediate
between much as the reason that i love
to watch cats do what they do and the
reason i love to watch monkeys do what
they do is that it's it's animal
behavior and i that i want to understand
what organisms are doing without the
overlay of their
damned explanations right because the
explanations you know the anthropology
of what's going on is very often now
you're in the
in the domain of like deceit and
self-deception which is itself
evolutionary and that's all very
interesting but uh
you know just as we have said again and
again you turn down the sound on your
conversations or in the conversations of
others and you will learn a lot more
about what is actually going on like
what people are actually feeling towards
one another and you can do that much
more easily without turning down the
sound if you're able to listen to people
and watch people
engage in the language that you are not
fluent in or don't speak at all and so
you know you get to engage with people
as as people you know rather than as
cats or as monkeys and like when you're
trying to engage linguistically i'm like
this sucks it's really hard for me i'm
trying um but then take a step back and
like okay this is awesome because i get
to see i get to interact with people
without having to in
internalize their stories about
themselves necessarily the way that when
you're in when you're in our your home
language it's very hard
to
say okay you know what i just don't want
to hear your stories at the moment i
want to watch what you do
yeah it's uh it's absolutely revealing
it's also fascinating to find out you
know when you do
spend time like we've had guides for
example uh who we've you know
taken for a week into on karana for
example where we do have some shared
language enough to to get by but not a
lot and
um it's amazing you know how
you think that a friendship is based on
what you say to each other and the fact
is
that's part of it but it's but it's not
it's not the majority of it and so you
can you know you can genuinely really
like and respect the character of
somebody that you've heard very little
from and aren't in a great position to
say exactly what they said yeah well and
i'm just thinking you know you do end up
with little linguistic shared things
that become you know like the foundation
for your for your friendship and so
you know i'm thinking specifically of um
it was probably angelique
in ankarana which is in northern
madagascar the very first time we were
there maybe it was the second time we
were there
um
in which um we you know
and this happened over and over again in
madagascar things never come when
they're supposed to and so you know
you're waiting for a boat and you're
stranded and like okay is it gonna come
tomorrow
um
maybe tomorrow is it going to come
tomorrow pizza and
pizza which literally means maybe
tomorrow and figuratively means almost
certainly not tomorrow right and also
means how would i know
you're here just like i am how do i know
and then because you know malagasy was
their first language and english was our
first language and we came together in
french ish uh you know their french was
generally much better than ours
they'd say
potato maybe right
that's what it may be you know so maybe
maybe maybe in you know three different
languages and they just keep repeating
it to us like okay and so it became sort
of this mantra even when you're like oh
are we gonna be able to get enough rice
for dinner on gamba patetra maybe are we
going to find the frogs today on gamma
potato maybe that's is a great example
because i think anjalik didn't quite
understand that that would be funny to
us he thought he was just sort of
covering it you know in all of the
languages in case we missed the first
necessary and then when we started
repeating it because it was funny it
became an inside joke for all of us
um
so yeah all these things um these things
frequently happen and they say a lot and
i will just say one more thing i'm
wondering if i have mentioned this
before if i have you'll tell me and i'll
stop but
um i used to run an exercise with
classes that i would take especially to
sun likes in washington where we would
spend a week in a place where um
you can basically hike without the trail
system because there's enough stuff up
above you that you can figure out where
you can dead reckon basically across
this wild habitat
and
for one day of the week we would make a
rule and it was sometimes uh called
silent day but it was not silent day the
rule was no use of language no reading
no writing no speaking the language but
you could do anything else you want you
could whistle you could make noises
right and so people went about their
normal activities
and they innovated
ways of doing things so a frisbee game
right
descended into like whistles and hoots
and things because you didn't really
need all that much language to play
frisbee right and you know walking on a
trail the way you ordinarily warn
somebody they're about to you know trip
on something you know these things take
on another character there's certain
things you can't suppress you can
suppress your language but then ouch you
know or you know [ __ ] right that just
you you the tourette's syndrome stuff
the tourette syndrome stuff emerges
anyway which tells you actually that is
really filed separately right yeah well
and and the failures are interesting too
so i didn't do this as often as you did
but we did do it on our big on our
11-week ecuador study abroad in the
amazon at shirapuno you know deepest in
the amazon we got on that trip and it
was and it was deep and so we did we did
a a no language day then and
i i was out walking alone hiking alone
and
i
came upon one of our best students i'm
not going to name him here i think i
think this may be in the book i don't
remember i'm not gonna name him here
because i didn't clear it with him
before before thinking i would tell the
story
um and he's
on the trail ahead of me coming the
other direction um with his binos up
looking into the into the canopy and i
sort of and i you know and he sees me
and from a distance he's like
walk quietly up as you always should if
you're in the when you're in the forest
if you want to see anything um and
uh and
we don't have any language and so he's
like clearly about to leave and so we
sort of share a little whatever it is i
don't even i don't even know how we
shared anything meaning of some kind
meaning of some kind and i'm looking and
i'm like
and he walks on the other way and i stay
there for a while looking at the sloth
in the trees that he was clearly looking
at and this part of the amazon was
very interesting like in central america
we have happened upon places with so
many sloths and in the amazon they are
much rarer and so there are a lot of
people students on our trip who are
really excited about sloths and they're
rarely seen it's hard to know how rare
they actually are yeah there's just
there are a number of places where i've
been where we've been in costa rica and
panama where you're just guaranteed to
see sloths and um
and it was i think this may have been
one of one or maybe two sloths that
anyone saw on this entire trip
and um so i can see i was still in the
forest for a couple of hours and i
continued on i think i came out to lunch
and so we're still not talking and then
come dinner time we decided to
to break the language thing for dinner
so that we know we're all sitting around
you know eating by candlelight for
dinner
and um
and i sat next to him i said oh man
thanks for pointing out that sloth that
was awesome he's like
what's love
what are you talking about like
what were you looking at and it was he's
a bird guy you know he's really into the
birds that he is i don't remember what
bird it was but he was looking at some
bird that i didn't see because i trained
my binozo on what looked like the same
place he had and i saw the sloth right
away and stopped there so you know i
could have also seen the bird and he
could have also seen the sloth if we had
been in a moment when we had decided
that we were allowed to speak but we
were honoring this you know this totally
artificial like we're not going to do
language now and oh my god thank you so
much that's awesome i don't think we saw
this we saw totally different things i
don't think you necessarily would have
both seen both animals i mean obviously
that's a possibility well if we had
language we would have known what we
were looking for right but i think one
of the likely out i mean the particulars
matter a lot in this case yeah right but
one of the likely things to happen in
that scenario is that you would have
walked up and he would have said sloth
right now he would have said who said he
was watching a bird and you would have
trained on the bird and the sloth would
actually have become invisible to you
this is a possibility
and so yeah language could have stolen
that sloth from me well that's one way
to think of it what the thing
this is such a high bandwidth mechanism
for plugging two brains into each other
that
the effect is that it's very hard you
don't realize that you're actually
looking through somebody's eyes just
because they've sort of given you an
immediate orientation to what they're
looking at and suddenly that's what you
see and you don't see what borrow my
perception for a moment right which is
what it's great for but the point is
until you turn it off you don't realize
how often that happens right you need an
experience like the one you're talking
about to even be able to calibrate it
and say well how often you know i mean
yeah it's a calibrator like like leaving
the
lock in your car off accidentally and
returning
and nobody's touched anything because of
course how often does somebody actually
try the door to your car right almost
never presumably right
all right let's do another little
section here uh let's see this is just
two and a half pages it's called
plasticity
again from chapter nine childhood
chapter of a hunter-gatherer's guide to
the 21st century
childhood
excuse me hold on
childhood and by extension parenting is
an interplay of love and release of
holding someone close while also giving
them freedom to explore even perhaps to
leave
in biology we speak of plasticity often
phenotypic plasticity to refer to the
many outcomes that are possible from the
same starting materials
roughly speaking a genotype say the
alleles for brown eyes produces a
phenotype the actual brown eyes
phenotype is the observable form of an
organism for many traits though a
particular genotype encodes information
for a range of possible phenotypes and
interactions with the molecular cellular
gestational and external environment
determine what phenotype will actually
be produced
phenotypic plasticity allows individuals
to respond in real time to changing
environments to avoid being canalized
into set patterns and life ways by their
genes
the skulls of dominant wild hyenas are
big and robust with large sagittal
quests on top and broad zygomatic arches
of their cheeks
both of these structures provide places
for muscles to attach much needed if
you're in the business of asserting your
dominance with your teeth
compare this to the skulls of hyenas
born and raised in captivity which have
no such structures
the different environments of wild
versus captive hyenas affect what form
or morph they have
in the same vein human children who
choose soft processed foods have smaller
faces as adults than those who grew up
chewing hard tough food
spadefoot tadpoles can grow slowly into
omnivorous morphs or if they are tightly
packed and running out of time and space
in the ephemeral pools in which they
live they can grow more quickly into
larger fiercer cannibal morphs and feed
on each other what morph a spadefoot
tadpole develops into is entirely
context dependent
when temperatures soar zebra finches
communicate this to their unhatched
chicks
zebra finch chicks whose parents told
them about high temperatures while they
were still in their eggs alter their
begging behavior as nestlings and when
they become adults they prefer harder
nest sites
even our critically important aortic
arch the first arterial branch off the
heart that takes oxygenated blood to the
body has several common anatomies within
human populations which can develop from
highly similar genetic starting gates
plasticity provides the possibility of
alternate phenotypes often through
simple rules that do not prescribe
precise outcomes the result ever more so
with increasing levels of complexity is
exploration of new territory literal and
metaphorical
one place that plasticity manifests in
humans is the wide variety of approaches
to parenting across cultures
in tajikistan babies and toddlers are
restrained for hours on end in cradles
known as gavora's
gavorahs are treasured within families
and passed down between generations
tajik children are the center of family
life mothers grandmothers aunts and
neighbors are always available and
immediately respond to cries from a
cradle baby with food singing or other
comfort
counter to western expectations though
within a few weeks of babies being born
they are placed in gevorah's provided
funnels and holes through which to pee
and poop and their legs and torsos are
tightly bound children thus cradled can
move their heads a little else
these children with little experience
crawling or attempting to walk in their
infancy do not walk as early as children
raised in the west
the world health organization's formal
expectations for when children started
to walk are between 8 and 18 months and
yet tajik children may not walk until 2
or 3 years of age
are the tajik babies dullards or
physically incompetent
no
in contrast
children in a rural kenyan village sit
and walk earlier than western babies
tend to
are the kenyan babies inherently
designed for greatness their precocious
motor skills predictive of early mastery
across domains
also now
variations in baby raising culture
across humans exemplify some of the
great plasticity that humans have
kenyan babies walk earlier than western
babies but all but the most severely
disabled western babies learn to walk
soon enough
weird parents are not just focused on
our children we are focused on the
metrics that are easily recorded and
conveyed to others the when of our
child's first smile word or step
once we have such metrics in hand we are
easily confused into imagining that the
when is a critical measure not just of
health but a future capacity
once again the easily measured thing the
calorie the size the date becomes an
inaccurate stand-in for a larger
analysis of the health of the system
by believing the false notion that when
a benchmark is met is the salient
measure of health and progress we play
into our modern fear of risk it is risky
for my child to miss a benchmark it is
risky for me not to force my child to
meet arbitrary deadlines such parental
focus can instill fear in our children
which they carry forward as an aversion
to risk
so important
if you don't learn to manage risk as a
child you won't be able to manage it as
an adult and you're very likely to
um
run afoul of the
full adult scale hazards yeah and so
maybe that's um
that then unless you had something right
away is a good way to segue into talking
about america's worst mom
wow i know she's a friend of ours you
know
i didn't yeah
leonard skinnezy wow oh right mom yep
yep so for those of you who don't know
um sure the second edition of her book
free range kids is just out um and it's
fabulous
um
except wait what what business does she
have talking about childhood she's
america's worst mom yes how'd she get
that description what her earned her
that delightful title in 2008 so she's a
new yorker she lives in new york city um
in 2008 she let her then nine-year-old
son find his way home alone
on the new york city subway he had been
begging her to let him do it
she did
from the article that she wrote which
we'll post in the show notes on the new
york sun quote long story short my son
got home ecstatic with independence
but of course the uproar was immediate
and fierce how could she have let her
precious cargo loose in the
terrible hostile environment that is the
a modern american city and in part her
position is
the city is supposedly safer than it's
been since the 60s like you know we've
we've gotten better but you know more to
the point
the the safetyism which is something
that she talks about and jonathan height
talks about and indeed the two of them
together along with um an excellent
psychologist named peter gray and also
daniel shukman
former chairman of fire started an
organization called let grow which is
specifically about creating children who
enjoy risk and have independence and are
anti-fragile
and
lenore who's a friend of ours uh
is an advocate for safe and independent
um childhood responsibility
and
just think about in light of i'll show
this later but um in light of that story
about what's going on in tajikistan and
what's going on in a rural kenyan
village
the the variety of approaches to
parenthood in functioning cultures you
know we're not talking about outliers
and psychopaths within cultures who are
abusers and frankly evil that's not who
we're talking about we're talking about
other cultures in which children
grow up to be adults who are functioning
and productive
that do things so differently from how
we do them and yet when american adults
stray from you know where we're weird
you know when western educated and uh
industrialized rich democratic
um
people in in countries that that
describes do things that go outside of
the current mores of sort of safetyism
and protectionism and
always looking over the shoulder of
children and informing them what they
should do and telling them what the
rules are and making sure they don't
stray
when when we go outside of that we are
told that we're putting our children at
risk
and you know this
this requires a bigger conversation
about risk which we will i think start
today and i mean we've been talking
about but maybe
we will be talking about for for some
time but
the idea that individual level risk is
the only risk that should be thought
about and that should be um
should be responded to
because it's the easiest to measure as
opposed to creating a society of people
who are incapable of doing the analytics
themselves and taking and taking
responsibility for their own risks such
that you then have a society level
problem a society level pathology really
in which people aren't capable of
figuring out what is true for themselves
well i do think uh in the interest of
balance we should point out that there
is some evidence that a relaxed
parenting style can lead to moderate to
severe cases of heterodoxy
and you know there's no telling where
that goes but
um
yeah so the other thing is in some sense
i mean here's the really uncomfortable
part of this
there is no there's literally no way to
raise your children so that they are
safe and are capable of managing risk as
adults the way you learn to manage risk
is through things not going completely
well and adjusting right yeah you you
manage risk complete you
take all risk out of a childhood and you
end up with a person in an 18 year old
body with the brain of a child and how
is it that they're going to continue
like how is it they're going to become
adults it's never harder plasticity does
get less and less acute the longer you
go you you develop right
in fact what you will get is colleges
full of children demanding that the
world be made safe around them right
right which you know i know that sounds
far-fetched but it could happen yeah
but so in some sense what we're saying
is
that um
if you keep your kids
safe that you are putting the adults
they will grow into at risk right that's
the counterintuitive point right well
and but not just that if you keep your
children safe you're putting the adults
they will grow into at risk they will be
less competent less productive more
fragile less capable in all realms
and furthermore and some parents will
say not my responsibility but
furthermore you are putting the society
into which you are moving them at great
risk
so you are also taking you're also
creating a cost that all of us bear
um by creating fragile children
and are they
do they have a higher chance of
surviving to their 18th birthday if you
put them in a bubble for those first 18
years yes they do
is that 18 year old someone who is going
to surprise you going to be creative
going to be productive going to be
analytically insightful going to be
industrious going to be capable
no
no but they're gonna be alive so you
know which which of these things
do do do you treasure more obviously we
want our children to be alive
but at the cost of everything else
everything else
a guarantee
almost a guarantee that by bubbling them
up for the first 18 years they will
survive and then what then you have a
perennial child and then you have a
society full of perennial children right
and you know
i think many of us have happened on
this realization from different paths
yeah i mean this is not so different i
mean it's not at all different really
from jordan peterson suggesting that you
not interrupt children while they're
skateboarding sure right it's the same
thing and the point is is skateboarding
safe
nope but it is a good way to break your
arm
and learn the lesson of how one breaks
their arm while you're young yeah and is
this safe zach you want to show this
right
so for those listening this is a picture
of our then are then eight-year-old son
toby
uh jumping off the fallen excuse me uh
the root mass of a of a big leaf maple
that had fallen in an ice storm the year
or two before um it's it's quite a ways
down and he's jumping into a mixture of
solar and oregon grape mostly not oregon
grape although i see some of it there or
i can grape being somewhat spiny
and he did it over and over and over
again and so did the dog and so did zach
and this just as the picture that i i
found you know is could he break a leg
he could
could he break his skull open
he could this isn't where you start
you don't start by jumping off the
highest thing into an uneven surface you
learn to fall
you you figure out how to deal with your
environment in small steps such that by
the time
you're eight you can do this and by the
time you're 18 you can do more yeah and
you know in fact we are of course wired
for these things um i have hypothesized
that we have many
weird characteristics uh
lowercase weird not weird country
characteristics but weird
characteristics designed to train us to
protect things that matter
right and my guess the prediction of the
model is that um you get hit in the
testicles more when you're young
right and that i didn't no
i'm sure you didn't but those of us who
did
right it's a very profound experience
and the point is anything that you do
that results in a likelihood of that
leaves a very clear imprint on you and
it trains you without anybody having to
wag a finger right you you understand
exactly what the problem is and you just
learn not to get hit in the nuts and
yeah i mean it's the difference between
knowledge gained by embodiment and
experience as opposed to being told you
know like dude play better tennis
cool done okay if it were that easy
which it's not and somehow in this
incredibly abstract
unfortunately far too postmodern world
in which so many of the people engaging
even those who say they've they've seen
the flaws of post-modernism and are not
going to engage in anymore so many
people are operating an entirely social
landscape like making arguments that are
about sociality as opposed about social
implications and what other people say
whether people think as opposed to what
is true like what what actually is true
and the way you know that best is by
physically engaging the truth of
whatever it is that you're trying to
physically engage well i do think
physically is the way you learn all
these basic lessons and then there's a
way to extrapolate so you can learn
lessons that you can't possibly afford
to learn yourself
i know it's become a joke in our family
but um i am quite a big fan of the
subreddit what could go wrong
because a lot of things can go wrong and
the most interesting things on what
could go wrong are the things that go
wrong repeatedly that you don't think
are likely to happen at all right those
are very fascinating things and um
anyway it does cause
so so the point and bonus you get ads
for divorce lawyers when you're looking
at what could go wrong
actually i did not i did not think about
whether or not i was browsing what could
go wrong when the divorce lawyer ad came
up but um
but anyway yes
there's a bunch of stuff you can learn
yourself and nobody has to tell you hey
don't get hit in the nuts again right
don't get hit in the nuts again no one
needs to say it right also hey
try not things you don't need school for
right try not to hit your funny bone
yeah got it all right right there's a
very good reason you know most people
don't realize that there's a good reason
for the funny bone thing and it has to
do with what happens to the nerves that
operate your very important hands as
they pass through a joint that can't
allow those nerves to be protected by
all the outer stuff and so you know
bumping your funny bone as a warning hey
if you keep doing that you're going to
lose use of your hand yeah right so
anyway
um
if you insulate your children from the
things that will cause them to get hit
in the nuts they might get hit in the
nuts as an adult which is a bad thing
yeah
indeed um so actually this totally
totally apropos this from uh one of
peter gray's excellent books free to
learn
why unleashing the instinct to play will
make our children happier more
self-reliant and better students for
life so i've just got a bunch of things
about play like let's talk about play
here
um
so he's quoting here a 1994. this book
was published his book is published in
i forgot i don't have it here um
this book was published more recently i
want to say 2014 but i think i'm making
that up 2013.
and he's
discussing here a 1994
description from an anthropologist named
martini
about um
children in polynesia on the basis of
martini's extensive observations of
children on the marquesan island of
uapu i have never been i don't know how
to pronounce that in the south pacific
researcher mary martini wrote the
following
13 members of a stable play group were
observed daily for four months and less
systematically for another two
children range from two to five years
old they played several hours a day
without supervision while their siblings
attended school nearby they organized
activities settled disputes avoided
danger dealt with injuries distributed
goods and negotiated contact with
passing others without adult
intervention
they avoided adults probably because
adults disrupted their play the play
area was potentially dangerous a strong
surf broke on the boat ramp the large
rocks on the shore were strewn with
broken glass the valley walls were steep
and slippery children played on a high
bridge and high sharp lava rock walls
remember this is children ages two to
five
machetes axes and matches were
occasionally left around and young
children played with these
in spite of these dangers accidents were
rare and minor
hitting teasing and scolding were
frequent but fistfights tantrums and
prolonged crying were rare
disputes were frequent but were
dissipated after a few minutes children
did not seek adults or older children to
settle conflicts or direct their play
this is what functional play and
childhood look like right and the you
just you need to map
the scolding that would come to you if
you took this lesson to heart and you
engineered a world in which these
lessons could be learned by children in
the way that they are learned in other
parts of the world um
you would be
potentially accused of child abuse and
yeah you could become america's worst
mom
you could take over for lenoir but um
i couldn't i guess i could now
by the way her her her two boys are both
young adults now and uh
successful and fine
and thrive and thriving in the live
human beings yes but i'm i'm reminded i
hope i have the story right but uh
martin mullen who is the um prime mover
behind the marble machine for which the
from
yeah
uh is that how it's pronounced
okay
get in touch we need to talk um but
anyway
the music for the theme music for dark
horse
he describes
uh
playgrounds
yes in which there you know
wood with nails sticking out of it just
you know playgrounds from hell in which
people actually children actually
learned how the world works but no i
mean this is a movement i think in
europe and i don't think it's really
spreading to the us yet but these
intentional playgrounds that have
these
these risks hazards right and you say
playground from hell but it's not like
this is a playground that was created
for you know utopia and has been allowed
to fall into disarray this is a
playground that has been created with
the risks embedded in them let's put it
to you this way if you look at the
marble machine and you think about what
it implies about the person that put it
together that person spent time on these
playgrounds with hazards
allowed to actually explore and figure
out how to build stuff and you know it
created a genius mind
now you can't say how much of that was
the nail sticking out of the boards but
something about this worked and so
anybody who would question it as
obviously wrong
doesn't know what they're talking about
which you know i don't know i'm sure
kids get hurt in those playgrounds but
i'm sure they do um but the point is the
fact that children get hurt yeah it's
not evidence you're doing something
wrong because again it's the adults that
you're putting at risk if they don't get
hurt and you know as with all of these
um
long-term questions
it's very hard if not impossible to do
the experiment
because
because the control is so far out and it
just requires longitudinal tracking so
you know you want to compare you want we
would want to and it's not going to
happen
compare
the children who spend time in those uh
playgrounds with the children who don't
but not as children like sure you can
compare injury rates and even death
rates as children but also look at how
they do as adults and you know the
various indicators of health and
productivity as adults and the
prediction here which is
um which has been made across domains
you know in many different specific ways
with regard to the value of risk and
adventure in play in childhood is that
those children who are exposed to such
things as children are much more
functional and productive and healthy
and frankly um
capable of avoiding real harm as adults
right which does not mean that it can't
go wrong of course of course it can and
you know how we are we are lucky we are
lucky we have you know we have
our willingness and in fact insistence
on exposing our children to to risk you
know none at first none at first right
this is this is not a like just expose
children to risk there's a you know
there's a developmental period and you
know you don't want your newborn uh to
ever think
that you don't have their back you know
and we talked about this either last or
you know a week week or two ago
but you know the older they get the more
capable they get letting them take more
and more risks getting farther and
farther away because they now are secure
in the knowledge that
they have one or two loving parents and
you know hopefully more can and more
friends around them who will come for
them if they need it and that allows
them
to take more and more risks such that
when they do step over that threshold
into adulthood they are actually
really capable and really able to
determine when they encounter things
they've never encountered before how to
assess
how to decide what to do next i think it
also makes sense to just point out that
you know there's no great way of doing
this right allowing your children to
face risks means running the risk that
something bad will happen yeah um
you know and the way we've managed it is
we have
rules
right and um
you know the rules in our house are
you're allowed to break your arm you are
not allowed to damage your eyes your
neck your skull your back which you are
allowed to break an arm or leg
and your central nervous system are off
limits off limits yeah and you know if
it happens we'll take care of you but
yeah you know but the point is anything
you do that results in an injury near
your eye the question is were you in
danger of violating that rule you know
because they then you're doing something
wrong and this i mean this is consistent
with not all injury is the same not all
harm is the same and
frankly i mean this is gonna seem like
we're going way off the rails here but
i'm reminded of the way that
that that me too went stupid right where
was it matt damon who i think who you
know said basically that frankly sexual
assault is different from
being patted on the ass when you don't
want to be patted on the ass and you
know some people will say well that was
sexual assault like actually
there are different degrees of of
awfulness and we need to be able to talk
about it and there's different degrees
of injury and so you know if any time
your kid
falls down and gets a scrape you run in
with your you know bucket of first aid
kit and you make sure to slather it with
iodine you make sure to put a band-aid
on you make sure to kiss it and tell
them it's all going to be okay well
they're going to think that might have
been the worst thing that could ever
happen to them and anytime anything that
happens to them and someone doesn't come
in with their bucket of first aid
they're gonna think they're being
mistreated and you know we didn't we
didn't apply very many band-aids to our
kids growing up and it's not because
they didn't have scrapes and and wounds
we said okay get back on the bike then
and you know sometimes it can feel like
but i just want comfort right now and
sometimes comfort is what's necessary
but
as as you started saying it is now i do
too
it's about the future you know what
happened happened there's no changing it
you can overlay your story on it and i
can overlay my story on it but what
happened happened
if we can both agree that whatever it
was wasn't good and would be better if
it didn't happen next time what can we
learn from it how can we move on let's
go have fun again but do it while
reducing the risk the thing that just
happened doesn't happen again reducing
the risk that it does happen again
um i will also uh just
maybe as a final cap on this there's
something about situations that are
actually dangerous
that
the most important thing about these
situations is that you not lose your
cool right the most important key to
getting out of a situation that you
might not get out of is
staying calm so you can think carefully
about what your actual options are
what is actually available to you that
isn't immediately obvious
these things and
the problem is if you insulate somebody
from
harm
they tend to freak out when anything
goes wrong and then they become a hazard
to themselves and you know it's like you
know when we were kids you know you and
i didn't know each other as kids but
growing up in la you go to the beach
somebody has to tell you actually that
when the when you start getting pulled
out by a riptide it's not an infinite
phenomenon a if you stopped fighting it
would it would give you up at some point
and you would be able to swim away
whereas if you try to fight it you'll
exhaust yourself if you swim
parallel to the beach you can get out of
it right but you know if you
are prone to panic and the first time
you experience a riptide you're an adult
and nobody is you know nobody takes an
adult aside and says by the way there
are riptides and if you get into one
don't panic it'll give it'll let you go
or swim parallel to the shore right if
nobody mentions that to you because
nobody talks that way to adults
then the point is you don't know what to
do and you may drown yeah um and so you
know i've
i've been lost in the amazon
with people and the ability to laugh
about it and to realize you know we
might actually be out
all night
could happen but we'll find our way back
there's a river we can figure out where
which direction from us it is
unfortunately there are a lot of rivers
but right but but the point is you know
there is a way out of this it may not
happen immediately and it may not be
comfortable in the meantime but you know
oh but i mean if when you're actually
lost in the amazon and i have i i was
once and only once really felt like i
was truly lost and i was all alone and i
thought
i actually i actually am not sure what
to do here um
yeah the stakes are very high right
because when you're actually deep you're
hundreds of miles from any permanent
settlement and you know there's one
direction there's one field station
somewhere near where you left from but
if you really can't figure out which
direction it is from where you are
because you've entered some sort of
bermuda triangle of the amazon that's
what it felt like in my case um you know
you you gotta you gotta get exactly that
or else you could be walking forever and
you probably will never see anyone ever
again well that's the problem especially
at night you are in danger once you've
made one error it's very easy to
compound it because especially you know
everything looks the same you think it
doesn't all look the same until you're
off trail and you're three meters off
and everything looks new and it's
amazingly difficult to find trails like
if you've only ever been on trails that
are maintained by you know a a weird
style organization right um then it
feels like well at least as soon as you
find the trail you'll know it's like no
you can just walk right across the trail
off of it and one and once you've done
it if you think the trail is that way
and you walk that way and you walk over
it which is especially likely at night
then you don't know whether the trail is
yet farther or you need to turn around
and once you've started talking yourself
into one of these things or the other
you can just compound the problem uh
dramatically so
the thing is in that case it's certainly
the panic that gets you too right and if
you if you start thinking all right at
least i want to know if i'm walking in
circles i need to mark you know as i
move i need to mark so i at least know
how to undo what i just did right um so
that sort of thing yeah so the moral of
this story is carry flagging tape
everywhere yes especially downtown
for sure
um
yeah i know that actually that's that's
a perfect segue to the last couple of
things um and then we can talk a little
bit more about them but um
we've already talked about we have
childhood in order to play it's not
plays on something we do to fill time in
childhood because what else are you
gonna do childhood actually extends in
length in order to create time for play
and i found so this is a terrific book
as well i'm going to put all these in
the show notes but david f lansey the
anthropology of childhood cherubs
chattel changelings
so he's an anthropologist who has done
as far as i can tell the only sort of
compendium of anthropological literature
on um on childhood and you can see how
many book darts i have in that so this
is this is a well-loved book um but
there's just one
yeah one thing in here 220.
um
he says
i know this is just amazing a hypothesis
from 1898 from a book called the play of
animals this guy named gruse
says animals do not play because they
are young they have their youth because
they play
that's that's early right like that's
that's just just post darwin so that's
remarkable and then just after that in
this book lancey describes um
something that fossey diane fossey uh
with the mountain gorillas said about
them so in rwanda's park the vulcan
volcan i can't speak you can't it's the
volcano park the mojo mountain gorilla
troupe first habituated by diane fosse
has several juveniles and play
especially after the morning feeding
session is almost non-stop so again as
in many of the great ape studies the
animals are being
provisioned in order to sort of bring
them into a place where they can be
observed so that is you know that it
they're not entirely in their
totally normal wild state but so they've
morning feeding play is almost nonstop
one juvenile repeatedly twirled himself
in a circle falling down an apparent
dizziness
i observed
this is this is fosse i observed
youngsters climbing up and down a
slender 5 meter high tree and
exaggerating the swaying motion as they
climbed dangling you from either hand or
foot while grasping and waving large
leaves they'd removed aside from solo
locomotor play on the ground and in the
tree juveniles chased each other in
games of tug
of tag and tussled in rough and tumble
play involving as many as three players
at a time they pulled each other off the
tree dropped bomb-like from the tree on
top of their playmates and rustled in a
rolling fur ball trying to distinguish
body parts among the entwined animals
was impossible in the space of 40
minutes the jungle gem tree they'd been
using had been utterly destroyed and the
surrounding low bush have been flattened
into a lawn
so
you know this happens in suburbia and no
adults let that happen right like you
just it's it's not allowed it's not
allowed but um
we
kids want to be able to do this and then
you know occasionally it's because they
want the destruction but usually it's
not the destruction is a side effect
and we need to be
allowing them into spaces where
destruction is allowed to happen
not because we want to encourage
destructive tendencies at all but
because we want to encourage rough and
tumble play unstructured play
you know falling on each other you know
all of these things tag and tug of war
and all of these things in which the
children themselves are deciding what
the rules are and who gets to play and
how to bring in others and
and how to scold others and how not to
run to the authorities whenever anything
goes wrong or someone's feelings get
hurt
yeah and you know you and i remember
how different a world it was in the 70s
and early 80s when kids used to play
with you know the neighborhood kids
would get together and play in the
street and the adults didn't necessarily
know where they were or yeah you know
when they were going to be back
and this changed as a result of
essentially a panic over the abduction
of children which obviously children do
get abducted but they weren't really
being abducted in large numbers from
their front lawns you know it's
typically people who know them who
abduct them and yeah and this is one of
these main points like we are just we
live in a culture of fear like fear is
being used to control us and for the
most part the things that you're scared
of the stranger danger isn't a danger
right and and it's a
bipartisan feeling about it it's a
byproduct of the way news even honorable
news collects stories that cause people
to watch and so it exaggerates the
hazards and caused effectively the death
of an entire type of play but what has
replaced it is the question right to the
extent that children instead of going
outside and riding their bikes and their
skateboards and their whatever else are
sitting in front of screens even if what
they're doing
has a value
it's consumptive rather than productive
right yes it is very rare i mean there
are exceptions i think you know um
why am i forgetting the name of that
computer game in which you build
minecraft
minecraft is a place where kids can be
productive in a
way that matters i don't know what
fraction of what goes on in minecraft is
that way but it's at least possible to
do useful stuff that actually teaches
you but to the extent that what you're
doing is just consuming content you know
you're actually training yourself to be
a consumer rather than training yourself
to manage risks and then there's the
question about what happens if your
childhood is filled with
um
super cool
snippets of video
right like amazing stunts and things
does that make you more likely to be
able to do amazing stunts or does it
make you feel like there's nothing you
could possibly do that would be
interesting because you've seen the most
amazing stunts yeah right
i'll never get there i'm not that good i
couldn't possibly achieve anything like
this why try right and you know you get
a lot of the joy of it
wow that's really cool and it is cool
but um but but the point is it doesn't
lead you in the right direction it
doesn't incentivize you you know your
friend does some cool wheelie on their
bike and you think yeah i want to do
that too and maybe you discover the
wheelie tree which is what allows you to
learn how to do a wheelie where you hang
on to a branch and
yeah balance your bike but but the last
thing i want to say is that the video
games especially video games the way
they exist now where you have these
massive multiplayer social games which
in the one way are better because they
are social so at least even if kids
aren't sitting with each other they get
interaction and they develop something
like a friendship and all of that yeah
but
the point is it
decouples the kind of camaraderie and
danger facing that we used to do in the
street with our bikes and whatever and
has put it into a realm where the
dangers aren't real and they probably
don't inform you very well about
anything in the real world right and
they sort of give you the social
reinforcement for something that isn't
useful it's wasting your mental capacity
for these things
and you know what what will that do to
adults yeah
well i'm reminded of um
i'm reminded of the
gang of kids
playing in the streets that i that i did
there was
i don't think it was
a consistent part of my childhood but
there was at least several months
when there were a number of kids in my
neighborhood and we played we played a
game that we called greek greek gods and
goddesses and we each we each chose one
of them
and to to embody and we roamed the
neighborhood in acting no
not rome
roamed
i know i just
sorry i was being a little pedantic yeah
yeah um
you know being being what we saw as you
know perhaps the best but also the worst
of of that person and um
know i don't i have a little bit of a
hard time imagining that everyone else
was as into greek mythology as i was at
that point but um but god it was so much
fun and so free and we were also
you know i grew up in west l.a in the
70s and 80s and
as i remember it anyway we were
certainly allowed to roam freely in
across all of the front yards and i
think across a lot of the backyards too
yeah and just you know do our in my case
i always i always chose athena i was
athena and i got to i got to do the
athena stuff in the in the neighborhood
with all the other boys and girls and
and it was just extraordinary sure it
was and you were so you were probably on
bikes often often on bikes but you know
i mean i remember all the kids in in the
neighborhood and it was
nearly
constant for much of the year you know
yeah well that's a benefit of course
being in southern california southern
california yeah right um and you know we
got into a lot of trouble and i think uh
almost none of that trouble was at my
instigation but um nonetheless i learned
a lot about trouble and why you
shouldn't get into most trouble and you
should get into other kinds of trouble
and how to tell the difference and all
of that and you know again i i i hate to
be the you know the
the wagging your finger and get off my
lawn guy but um but there is a question
about whether or not the play you are
engaged in
has any utility whatsoever with respect
to the adult stuff you're going to be
expected to do right and you know the
bike stuff the running around the
neighborhood the you know that stuff
had relevance right not exact it wasn't
precise but the point is
you know the same stuff that allows you
to navigate the hazards of biking around
your neighborhood and jumping off of
curbs and leaping over hedges and all of
that is about the physical world and
what can happen there yeah um i think i
think i'm going to disagree with you a
little bit here though i don't i think
that we specifically do not want to hold
play to any such standard i think we
want to encourage unstructured play in
which the children choose the thing and
i want it embodied i'm not i'm not
disagreeing with that i'm saying that if
somebody else has fed you a video game
in which the idea is that you're going
to
i don't know pursue
goodies of some kind or blow stuff up
the point is it's not even clear that
the lessons in it are inherently true
right unstructured physical play the
lessons are inherently physical yeah i
mean i guess the distinction for me
because i think you and i actually do
have a you know we aren't just opposed
to video games right like we have
actually seen it you know
in in many of our former students as
well that in some cases um gaming was a
way to allow them some social
interaction before they felt that they
were sort of capable of doing so
themselves and
um
that said for me the issue is one of
disembodiment but also one of of
consumption and so the the more
the more interactive such that you can
actually change the rules of the game
and decide your own fate and interact
with others and they can also give you
feedback on what it is that's going on
um the better the game is and so you
know an entirely passive thing
uh is the the least play-like right
right and it's and it's the most
school-like frankly and that's part of
why school is failing the way that it is
um well i'm gonna make the same point i
always make which is i mean it's
actually two different points one is
it's not the box it's the business model
yeah right when the idea of the video
game is to keep your attention and
prevent you from wanting to do anything
else because it's so what you're doing
is so visually rewarding or puts you in
situations that are so socially
rewarding whatever whatever it is the
point is you've optimized for something
that isn't about you it's for whatever
corporation made the thing right um
and the other is that you know there's a
i hate to make this point about play but
i think it is actually in some sense the
central theme of what we've been talking
about is
uh it's all well and good to have fun
when you're playing and you should fun
is one of the driving motivations but
the purpose is not
entertainment right the purpose is not
even recreation recreation is the wrong
modality the idea is to usefully upgrade
your software and the reason that play
is fun is because if you do it your
software gets upgraded well it's the
distinction and it's one that we make in
the book although not on this particular
point
between the junk version of something in
the full version so junk food junk sex
junk play yep right totally junk play is
the perfect perfect description yep yeah
so one one last thing um
there's a an article from 2001 which you
can show briefly here zach called
mammalian play training for the
unexpected uh published in
the uh quarterly review of biology
uh in 2001 as i say um and their their
functional hypothesis that they make
here is that play enables animals to
develop flexible kinematic and emotional
responses to unexpected events in which
they experience a sudden loss of control
specifically
and that may not sound all that new it's
from 2001 but this article is actually
great it's in quarterly review so it's
it's a big journal it's a
good journal and a very good article and
they make actually i didn't write down
but i think it's like 24 different
precise predictions this article which
is just a really good sign
so let me say but i just want to share
the first prediction here um but first
they say and it's a review article so
they they say play is nearly ubiquitous
in all mammalian orders which suggests
either a common ancestry for play or or
similar selective pressures on all of
those different orders
and there may be some of that but
clearly the most parsimonious
explanation is that play is part of
being a mammal
um
right did you have some someplace
further you were going well i mean i've
got a lot of stuff but go for it okay um
the their major hypothesis as i said
although this is um
their just their description of it as
opposed to in the abstract is that a
major ancestral function of play is to
rehearse behavioral sequences in which
animals lose full control over their
locomotion position or sensory spatial
input and need to regain those faculties
quickly
and further
a sort of a sub hypothesis
is that we hypothesize that animals in
play learn how to deal with the
emotional aspect of being surprised or
temporarily disoriented or disabled
and then um they're oh wait furthermore
in adverse social situations emotional
overreaction may lead to undue
escalation of conflicts
so that you know that right there and
that is what we're seeing sort of
society-wide and then let's see i've
highlighted the first prediction
if i can find it here we go
prediction from this article the amount
of play experience obtained affects the
ability to physically and emotionally
handle unexpected events and temporary
handicaps
animals deprived of play be it by
natural circumstances or artificial
manipulation will be less able to deal
with such situations
so in some ways if you interface this
with the
various models in our book
this is a rehearsal for
useful
application of consciousness that
effectively the conscious mind is
navigating situations for which you
don't have a pre-written program
and that you know if you're thrown by
such a situation then you're not going
to be in it you know basically you don't
have enough practice with your conscious
mind in order to deploy it usefully
and bad things will happen you could as
we were talking about a few minutes ago
you could take a situation in which
something has gone wrong and panic your
way into death or
into further lostness in the amazon or
whatever whatever it is that happens and
let me just say not just panic your
weight necessarily but anxiety your way
too i think anxiety is um by many
measures a sort of a lesser form of
panic and that the the rise of anxiety
disorders um is exactly in line with the
decline of children being allowed to be
children oh this is this is good because
if you think about if you put all these
models together the idea is that which
is unexpected ought to trigger your
conscious mind which needs to have
played usefully in order to know what to
do when it is triggered and if you
interrupt this process then the thing
that should cause you to go into the
secondary mode where you figure out how
to usefully get out of your situation or
to make some other value from it yeah um
just results in paralysis or chaotic
behavior or whatever yeah your your
nervous system is just constantly
triggered like actually you're just in
high alert all the time and
you you can't be calm and you can't make
good decisions and you can't innovate
yep
yeah
does look a bit like what we're seeing
it does it does
anything else um i think we're there
all right uh well then uh this brings us
to the end of another episode of
darkhorse um
for those of you watching rather than
just listening we're going to take that
15-minute break and then be back with a
live q a
you can ask submit questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
we do not get to all of them but we get
to many of them
please consider joining our patreons we
very much appreciate the support
if you're watching on youtube consider
also watching on odyssey we are still
fully demonetized on youtube
and
that is hopefully going to change at
some point but uh but we don't know
uh you can get shirts at
store.darkhorsepodcast
email any logistical questions not
questions for the q a but logistical
questions to darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com
please consider coming over to
dot naturalselections.substack.com join
for free and you get emails when i post
new pieces every tuesday
and subscribe to all four of our
channels if if you would on youtube and
on odyssey brett weinstein's main
channel and also dark horse podcast
clips
and like
uh share
spread widely
anything else uh achieve excellence
achieve excellence be good to the ones
you love eat good food and get outside
be well everybody